how long do we put those strong
sanctions and tariffs on Iran what was
the timeline of that well they're still
on okay yeah and and is it still it's
the tariffs are irrelevant to Iran it's
more just the financial sanctions on oil
right and the thing you have to
understand about financial sanctions and
oil is oil is priced in U.S dollars
and and as long as oil is priced in the
US Dollars Iran can be hurt by that but
the problem now is we've got the Saudis
flirting with the the commas Chinese
um and agreeing to trade in Yuan which
is the Chinese currency and that that
provides an opening for Iran and the
Middle East to and you know if you if if
we stop trading worldwide oil in dollars
that has its own
to implicate do you think the sanctions
and the and the tariffs that we had on
China on you know Russia on Iran all
these that we had do you think that that
unified them because they are okay so so
Russia China Iran Saudi and even maybe
Brazil they're all looking at saying oh
yeah let me give you an example because
you just I thought you were going in a
slightly different direction it's like
when Rocket Man in North Korea was given
us such a freaking hard time boss wanted
to break bring Rocket Man under control
we slap sanctions on on them
um and and told the common is Chinese
you know like don't be giving them
oiled and anything like that otherwise
we're sanctioning you we didn't enforce
that stuff and we could see it you talk
about I mean I can tell you something
from the the top secret briefings
because it wound up in the New York
Times eventually
um you could see like these these uh
ships that would go out
uh you know Chinese would would send it
to Vietnam the tankers would go out in
the middle of the ocean and then they'd
switch them and then off that oil would
find its way uh to North Korea to heat
the Palace of uh Kim Jong-un well people
in North Korea starve and freeze but the
point is that
unless those sanctions are hard and
tight like a Nolan Ryan fastball all
you've done is create this alternative
currency monster which is where we're
heading now sir okay so so we can skip
that part because in my own mind I just
kind of wanted to know that some of
those tariffs maybe unified our enemies
and now they got stronger and they're
realizing you know what here's how we're
going to deal with that not the tariffs
the same sanctions separate matter it's
a totally separate matter tariffs what's
more painful
um well it depends on the country for
Iran clearly Financial sanctions right
because they don't they don't trade a
lot in other Goods right when did they
remove when we when they're they're
still on they're still on yeah is there
some form of sanctions still on Iran
because look if Iran gets the bomb yeah
Israel is like like maniacally and
rightly focused on making sure that Iran
doesn't doesn't get the capability of
dropping the big one because damn well
they'll use it but Iran I mean look
come and shine is at the at the top
right I I think Iran is more dangerous
than Russia far more dangerous because
you they basically you know we went in
with a stupid endless war in Iraq and
now Iran basically controls Iraq
dangerous in what regard to the world to
U.S yes absolutely because they they
want to kill the great Satan I mean
there's there's no question about Iran
wanting to take down the United States I
mean go back to colemany's statements
about the great state in America right
and and they uh they're they're
basically a breeding ground for for and
what I fear from China
is not nuclear weapons right now that's
not the way they're going to do it
they're going to do it through this
unrestricted Warfare techniques
blockchain technology to disrupt their
financial system viruses to take out our
uh electric grid and other types of uh
capacity
um we haven't even talked about the the
Wuhan virus yeah I was going to say
actual viruses yeah I mean look they
learn
boy did did
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]